lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en las diferentes formas que
existen para la traslación de un punto y
después trasladaremos un punto en el
plano coordenada nos dicen dibuja la
imagen del punto p después de aplicar
una traslación de cinco unidades a la
izquierda y tres unidades hacia arriba
vamos a hacer lo que nos dice el
enunciado y luego veremos otras formas
de describir esto el punto se mueve
cinco unidades a la izquierda comenzamos
aquí y nos movemos cinco unidades a la
izquierda una dos tres cuatro y cinco
luego nos dicen que hay que moverse tres
unidades hacia arriba una dos tres por
lo que la imagen del punto p está aquí
después de aplicar la traslación que
describe el enunciado existen otras
formas de describir esta traslación en
el enunciado se usan palabras solamente
cinco unidades a la izquierda y tres
unidades arriba pero hay otra forma que
quizá parece sofisticada pero es
bastante intuitiva debe escribir una
traslación
comenzamos tomando un punto con
coordenadas x
donde la coordenada x indica la posición
del punto en el eje horizontal
a la derecha oa la izquierda y la
traslación indica que son cinco unidades
menos por lo que el punto trasladado
tendrá su coordenada horizontal como x
menos 5 coma y la coordenada jake que
indica la posición del punto en el eje
vertical
el enunciado dice que se traslada 3
unidades arriba y + 3 lo que esto quiere
decir es que cualquiera que sean las
coordenadas x y xi de un punto esta
traslación dice que se resta 5 a la
coordenada x esta parte significa 5
unidades a la izquierda y esta otra
parte de aquí dice que se suma 3
unidades a la coordenada jeff es decir 3
unidades hacia arriba incrementa la
coordenada y en 3 y disminuye la
coordenada x en 5 unidades
vamos a probar esta expresión general
con las coordenadas del punto p la
coordenada x del punto p estrés y la
coordenada y es menos 4 así que para
trasladar el punto 3 menos 4 vamos a
sustituir la x por 3 y la aie por menos
4 comenzamos con 3 y con menos 4
vamos a restar menos 5 al 3 como lo
vemos aquí arriba y sumamos 3 a la ley
que es menos 4 observen que en lugar de
la equis puse el 3 y aquí también puse 3
en lugar de la equis en lugar de lassie
puse menos 4 y también lo hice de este
lado otra forma de escribir esto es que
pasamos de 3 menos 4 a 3 menos 5 es
menos 2 y menos 43 es menos 1 cuáles son
las coordenadas de este punto en efecto
son menos dos menos uno esta fórmula
algebraica muestra cómo mapear las
coordenadas e indica la relación entre
las mismas
más adelante encontrarán preguntas donde
le solicitan dibujar la imagen de algún
punto como lo vimos en este enunciado
trasladando ciertas unidades hacia un
lado o ciertas unidades arriba o abajo
pero también se encontrarán fórmulas
como esta pero lo importante es que
reconozcan que esto indica tomar la
coordenada x y restar 5 que significa
moverse 5 unidades a la izquierda y esto
indica tomar la coordenada y sumarle 3
osea moverse 3 unidades arriba
quizá después de esto les pregunten cuál
es la nueva coordenada o quizá les pidan
que la dibujen como en este ejemplo pero
recuerden que todo es parte del mismo
concepto nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo